va bene tra tutti ben più sanità lui e
berlino
oggi nuova challenge giochiamo a
nascondino però giochiamo a nascondino
con berlino berlino cosa stai facendo a
giudizio è certamente berlino dovrà
trovarmi tale contrattino a 20 e io
dovrò andare a nascondermi non riesce a
trovarmi per più volte vince berlino se
invece io riesco a non farmi trovare per
più volte vinco io mi raccomando adesso
di un bel mi piace questo video se
volete vedere altre sale con merlino il
nostro casilino e poi sogno prendere dei
pop corn e mettetevi comodi e iniziamo
subito lasalle ok ora vitale conterà
fino a 20 aiuto fra un nas contro prodi
via ora 24
[Musica]
secondo poi merlino riuscirà a trovarmi
dentro l'armadio chiudere bene
altrimenti mi vede anche se merlino
sicuramente a trovarmi qui sono usciti
se dall'altra parte non mi ha visto
mi piace stare male
torino non li ho trovati dai band armati
mila mentre vaga fornirà non racconti
nei tagli questa deriva allora siamo 10
vinto berlino primo round
ora secondo round vitale conta va da
nascondere
le scale su ok
non so se riuscirò a farmi quaratino 14
15 17 18 20
torniamo londra berlino e uno stick
abbiamo subito a cercare motrici a no
qui interessato all'euro che a cercare
la vita
andiamo piace farla abbiamo cercato
mannino si chiama si è sentito il
titolare di vita come nel primo è molto
più interessato a sgranocchiare del sole
tra tre anni fa
o terzo turno questa volta cercherò di
farlo un po più difficile
ok questa volta in loro partiranno dalla
camera da letto così un po più di spazio
merlino vieni lino guarda che c'è qui il
tutto kg
quello che resta del tuo giochino in
realtà perché dolose sgranocchiato tutto
lo so lo so il tubino berlino dobbiamo
venisse raccontare meno di 20 kg puro 23
merlino 45 se 13 14 15 16 17 18 giorni a
berlino
andiamo a cercare padroncina dobbiamo
cercare cucinare
cerca cerca di qua ma per lì non vuole
salire sopra perché preciso dei suoi
giochini da questa volta cercando di
crocetta neve armato di nuovo ma no non
credo
no marino non si muove quindi bis
trasferì ad ora mi sto muovendo nella
direzione sbagliata tutelino meno
[Musica]
perché gli utenti fallibile però ci ha
messo un po a trovarmi infatti sto
mandando in giro per le stars salva
tutto in ballo quarto turno per questa
volta sì io risponderò vitale vediamo
sembra lì non lo trova più velocemente o
meno con strumenti e magari non lo trova
proprio vediamo la differenza con dove
andrà a cercare il suo giochino invece
di cercare a me vediamo prima volta da
berlino è innamoratissimo di vitale dove
devi capirlo pronti 12 10 11 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 19
[Musica]
berlino sta già ascoltando si sta
concentrando con l'este orecchiette
vediamo quanto è bravo trovarlo in
quanto tempo lo trova e capaci sniffando
dove dice che qua dietro non merlino non
mi sembra che sia equa state affatto il
sito berlino dove il ticino vista che
merlino questa volta 121 dove il
pollicino
[Musica]
proviamo a fare silenzio
io non sento niente merlina tu con il
tuo fiuto infallibile dovresti sentire
l'odore di patrocino no non può essere
dentro cestino non c entra la destra 9
mentre noverino stai cercando nel posto
sbagliato
berlino il bambino ti assicuro che non è
li guarda ti faccio vedere ricoveri
padroncino qua dentro
non mi credi ancora come sarà quel
rumore
berlino 6 mesi la saf e mi sa che in
berlino ma pensate sia sotto il tavolo
sta di fatto però non capisce dove forse
berlino perderà questo turno perché non
è riuscito a trovarlo
ok allora contiamo fino a 20 e se
berlino non riesce a trovarlo avrà vinto
vitale
[Musica]
ma povero mar meno doppione padroncino
[Applauso]
non mi trovato lino allora siamo 3 a 1 1
è un punto per vitale e tre per merlino
questo è l'ultimo turno io mi dovro
nascondere dovrò cercare di farlo il piu
difficile possibile e vediamo chi vince
vediamo se berlino resi a trovarmi anche
questa volta pronte ok prende la camera
vitale siamo pronti per l'eroe 5 6 7 8 9
udc siamo pronti 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
di cominciamo cominciato diciamo noi lì
con l'apporto qui pronta ad uscire
cercato cercato
30 di cosa è andata berlino nostri parti
strada dei giochi di berlino
[Musica]
dove dove cerca cerca mar nero arriva
qualcuno si è dimenticato dove ciabatte
qui marino te ne stai cercando delle
piante che cosa si è incastrato nel
treppiedi no non è quasi dentro non puoi
essere dentro pato lucida e allora
vogliamo queste terapie di esame ti fai
male dove cerca cerca berlino circa no
non è neanche nelle piante dati
progettare le fianco all'altro queste
secca cerchiamo c'era chi cerca dove i
documenti e sentito qualcosa casalingo
sul letto
non ce l'ha fatta
mi sa che qualcuno sta vincendo di loto
fa ci sono troppi indizi le ciabatte in
per terra le bolle forte che si chiamano
verissimo vero berlino si è vicino si è
vicinissimo berlino
sei troppo vicino troppo bravo net e la
portiamo questo gioco merlino è
bravissimo
oggi punti stiamo quindi quindi ma
finora ci ha scoperto per quattro volte
quindi stiamo 410 ma io ho perso mi
veramente questa carta
non esisterebbe una volta pensavo che mi
sarebbe stato super complicato trovarli
visto che sono in alto invece il bambino
che era il bravissimo ed è riuscito a
trovarsi lì ha fiutato subito perché ha
tenuti aiutato tutti è tornato magari
perché io sono profondamente il profumo
invece altera gente proprio biglietto
lascia mangiare volete continuando per è
lo stop per vederlo ti spunta fuori
qualcuno allora lasciate un bel mi piace
se volete altre challenge con berlino se
volete un'altra challenge nascondino
così diteci pure che altre sale se
volete vedere nei commenti
la scordiamo una crocchetta berlino alla
fine a savoca 4 castellini su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e
valorizzare ciao